there are political decisions that are
about complicated policy or nuanced
multi-factor decision-making and then
there are other political decisions that
are merely simple moral issues like for
example we make sure that when
hurricanes are coming we put the money
in place to help with a disaster
recovery and hurricane relief FEMA is
the agency the federal agency
responsible for coordinating and
managing a hurricane recovery a lot of
people had never heard of FEMA before
Hurricane Katrina and the absolutely
disastrous federal government response
to that hurricane in New Orleans FEMA is
an organization that does many different
things there are funds that are for FEMA
which are specifically for disaster
recovery but then there are also more
sort of general funds for FEMA that go
into infrastructure and training and
readiness but the big picture is that
all of that money together is what funds
the ongoing activities of FEMA which is
to help when emergencies take place just
as a massive hurricane hurricane
Florence is bearing down on the
southeast of the United States we
learned that the Trump administration
decided to take nearly ten million
dollars nine point eight million dollars
in funding from FEMA's budget and
transfer it not to education not to
health care not to who knows what but to
ice the organization that is involved in
the deportation and separation and
detention of immigrant and migrant
children and we know about this because
Democratic Senator Jeff Merkley has the
documents provided them to MSNBC's
Rachel Maddow last night who is making
the point that the funds that were
originally allocated to be for FEMA now
could end up being used to lock up
little kids in cages and internment
camps now it seems pretty cut and dry
it's a disgusting budget decision but
the Trump administration does have a
defense I'll tell you what it is and
then
think about whether it's a defense that
that makes sense
the Trump administration claims that
even though on paper yes 9.8 million
dollars was moved from the FEMA budget
over to the ice budget what they're
saying is that that nine point eight
million specifically couldn't or
wouldn't have been used for a response
to Hurricane Florence because of
appropriation limitations that they say
that may be true on the most technical
level but the money was taken from FEMA
so this becomes a sort of this dollar is
different than that dollar argument it
becomes sort of a basic conversation
about the fungibility of money even if
these nine point eight million dollars
weren't for hurricane relief when you
take away nine point eight million
dollars from FEMA which was going to be
used for training and infrastructure and
IT it doesn't really matter whether it
was under the ledger heading of response
money for Hurricane Florence or for 2018
hurricanes it's still going to impact
FEMA's ability to do response to
emergencies which is what they do and in
fact FEMA is saying because we're losing
that 10 million we have to cut back on
training we have to cut back on travel
we have to cut back on public engagement
sessions which are often used to educate
the public as to what it is that they
should do to be ready for different
types of emergencies that might be
relevant in their part of the country
and the fact that it wasn't specifically
cash for hurricanes it doesn't make any
difference
and both DHS and FEMA officials former
DHS and FEMA officials are saying
doesn't matter this is bad for hurricane
relief no matter what no matter how it
was earmarked we are now at the start of
hurricane season and it does not matter
what ledger heading was assigned to this
money this is a disaster particularly
given the disasters that FEMA has
experienced over the last 10 and 15
years when it comes to hurricane
response now we'll Trump space care
it's kind of an interesting question
because on the one hand we've had
situations where there's been a disaster
in a bluer area or at least a part of
the country represented by democratic
elected officials and we've heard from
both Republican voters in other parts of
the country and Republican elected
officials in other parts of the country
that they need to pull themselves up for
the bootstraps rather than waiting
around for federal government handouts
the problem with that argument has been
that as soon as there was an issue
elsewhere like for example tornadoes in
the center of the country the same
Republicans who said government isn't
there to take care of these liberals in
New Jersey in New York after Hurricane
sandy we're then saying oh well no I
mean this is different we have
hurricanes I'm sorry we have tornadoes
and floods that are affecting us now so
we do need the federal money so quite
frankly I don't know what the trumpets
about this we know that there seems to
be a significant double standard on when
the government should help with relief
and shouldn't help with relief but we
now have a hurricane followed by
multiple tropical depressions which
could become hurricanes that are heading
in the same direction mostly to red
areas maybe that will change their minds
it's just really it's a disappointment
that for many people on the right until
they're personally affected by something
it's like it doesn't exist they don't
really care and you know that if there
is a disastrous response to hurricane
Florence if it is bungled it's not going
to be Trump's fault it's not going to be
Republicans fault it's going to be the
fault of either Obama or Democrats or
it's going to be Hillary's fault it is
not going to be Trump that takes the
blame from his supporters if that
response is bungled truly horrible and
this is not just you know I don't really
like the phrase just politics because
we're talking about politics but
people's lives hang in the balance here
this is more than just politics but
that's what politics is it's it's life
and death for many people